okey dokey um the only reason why
there's no audio other than my voice
right now
hello everyone is because i think the
moment i start the game
the uh cinematics going to play so
i'm going to try to fire up the game now
thanks for everyone's patience i know
the beta technically started at about 10
a.m pacific this time
um
but hopefully all things go the way it
should
and hopefully you all can hear me
because i'm gonna fire up the game
and
and of course it's
not sized properly
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
so marius
at last i find you
yes
yes now
how i recognize you
i should have known you traveled in the
skies
there
they're always watching
i've been searching for you for a long
time malius
i was rather beginning to think you
didn't want to be found
oh forgive me tyrion please
it
wasn't my fault
not your fault
tell me malice how was it not your fault
the wanderer
yes
it was
[Music]
people said
[Music]
uh all right so
we're gonna go cali
uh paladin's one of my favorite
characters
uh hopefully audio is okay for y'all
sorry as i ask and chat if you can hear
me
because i do see levels but i just
i know gameplay
you're soft and it's so loud okay uh
give me one sec let me toggle gameplay
down a bit and then i will boost my
microphone as well so apologies as i
try to do that real quick
also thanks to the chat for um
acknowledging that
voice is too quiet game is too loud
yeah let me
[Music]
all right let's do it
forget the
oh there you go so g is to switch back
to old okay
so uh thanks for it thanks everyone for
tuning in uh my name is eric tay with
gamespot uh i will cleanse this
wilderness well i've played a lot of
diablo ii and lord of destruction in my
time was this uh lucky enough to be able
to play in also the
uh technical test the first time
the tech uh what's new in this one is
there you can play the paladin you can
also play the druid both those
characters were not playable in the
first one
uh also believe that um
there's multiplayer i'm not mistaken as
well
sounds much better
go man ignore the trolling you got it oh
we had some
rubber banding there
oh
also for those who watch later and watch
me by stamina pots the reason why is
because of what just happened there
good old stamina management
there we go den of evil
ooh trade chats going huh i don't think
that was there last time
how many of the chad uh used to be in
those good old trade channels we're just
scrolling really fast and it's like two
sages for a shaco or i don't know i
don't know if that's the right price but
back when sages were getting duped and
all that fun stuff
sorry to hear that you're not able to
log into ps5 um
to get the early access i hope it works
for you at some point i haven't been
monitoring the um status on each
platform i'm playing on pc for those
that are curious oh you can probably
tell because of the like hud and ui and
stuff ooh there's a ring
definitely picking that up
gonna kill all these guys
we'll see i think we should be able to
get through
act two hopefully um i'm probably gonna
play for about an hour and a half to two
hours that should be
we'll see i think i can get through act
two i don't know we'll see it kind of
depends
uh stats
i'll go vitality
i think we'll
start off with white i think just get
some free damage
i want assaj oh um that's the other
thing uh how many people in chat have
actually ever got a sodge drop
and that you didn't like bought it i've
only ever gotten one sage like legit
myself playing in my like entire time of
getting uh
playing diablo 2
and uh lod and
the
funny thing about that is like they
don't there's not really a way to track
time like you can in these days of how
much you've played but i've definitely
logged my hours um
oh a chipped ruby that's good
and um i've only once ever gotten a
diablo clone to show up randomly while i
was uh in a game with my buddy just
doing some muelling
and that was fun
you think that this is clunky xenics74
cause like man if we go back to the uh i
can go back to the old version
of the game
and i feel like that's
way more clunky i guess
man am i getting hit like randomly even
though there's no animation for it
uh we will probably pick up
sacrifice now
get that on
to vitality again
don't really need all this stuff but
i'll pick it up
uh my attack rating please
what is wrong with the server can't
connect i don't know i all i know is
that some people in chat were mentioning
that europe's server might be down but i
can't confirm that because i'm on
playing on n a
uh sorry that you haven't been able to
log in for an hour pure poetic hope that
gets fixed for you um i know that for me
i couldn't play i couldn't log in at
least for the first 15 minutes or so
like it was it was not loading for me
when even though i saw other people
playing it oh no
the dreaded one monster left
also we kind of got unlucky with the the
the rare mob
drop in kind of nothing oh
i think we take this
take this damage sash
uh it is eu servers are done uh sorry to
hear
um
that's that's a stinker
so pro uh we're probably selling that
energy ring
hopefully it's in this corner that i
didn't explore because if you if there
if the monster is not there i i don't
know
oh this is awkward
ah there he is hiding in the corner
uh i think we can we'll blow the tp he's
done we'll blow the tp it's okay
yeah there might be some latency mike um
i was i felt like i was getting hit too
but
you have to imagine that there's
probably
more people in this
um
iteration than than the last
so that some of that might be from that
we'll just equip we'll just equip
everything last time i was just like
whatever
how much is a scepter
all right oh
uh
i want holy fire so
i might just save on skill for now
and i guess sadly we got to make the run
again
because
uh yeah
i was gonna say maybe i go back to uh
den of evil in the back but
i know some people do um run to the cold
planes and then do dinner people but
yeah
i think server wise um
integrated dreadfuls it's always been
like that to some degree with blizzard
games like they
like even for like a wow expansion right
they they they know that there's going
to be a huge load but i think they just
try to compensate as much as they can
and then they know it's going to storm
uh normalize
but uh who knows for for these tests
because there's a there's a closed beta
or like i don't know if this is closed
it's early access beta i guess this this
weekend and then there's going to be an
open beta um next week weekend we'll
probably stream again then i'll probably
do maybe drew it that day instead since
we're doing paladin today
although personally i've never been a
big
i've never been a huge druid fan
i think my favorites is paladin
sorkin amazon i think those are my
three my top three personal favorites
diablo
get the coal planes waypoint
uh how much of the like um
you guys want me to do like every quest
you think or just kind of blitz through
it so like
i could avoid um
i feel like i'm missing a bunch
uh let's do like
get some attack rating get some decks
for the attack rating uh i can either do
like
as many of the missions or or quests or
we just uh kind of book it
probably do the the tower or the
countess and then probably do and and
dario
and then if we happen to get the malice
from butcher or whatever we can do that
too
i mean i don't know if i have working
servers which just happened to be in the
n a but i'm glad
you're here to to hang out i appreciate
everyone hanging out and hitting
chatting it up
um
it was really cool seeing the cinematics
if you haven't seen the cinematics i
would i would say go check those out
there
we have both um on gamespot.com as like
one video but you can also just watch
the individual ones if you want
uh just like crazy how different they
look uh we also did a like kind of like
a side-by-side comparison of just the
old
um the old
cinematics and just compared them i
guess we're burial ground so we'll just
do
just do it because why not should be
able to
own her pretty quickly
come here blood raven
got her
she didn't drop much though
but she that that might be worth do we
gotta oh
a little socket a little socket action
we got two chipped rubies we are we are
straight
we're gonna be um
pretty pretty strong here i think
eu servers are down um
do you know if you're able to swap to n
a and play because i know in the past
you could just switch regions and still
play but there might be more latency for
you um
but i mean playing
is with latency is probably better than
like no latency
issues you know what i mean so it's a
trade-off
i've definitely in the past i think for
d3 i've switched
um
cert regions
and if that doesn't work then i
apologize that was a maybe that wasn't a
great
um
tip i suppose
if anyone wants to see like the uh
what it would look like on the old
version we can easily toggle
check that out
uh
ratio quit says paladin's my favorite
awesome
i'll probably roll holy fire and then we
can if we get high enough to
come back to respect we can always go
hammers
just because hammers are just so solid
i wanted a better update
i was there 20 years ago ah hey man
or hello uh let me see sorry i missed
the name
oh it's xenix um
for me it's great like i actually
thought this game was uh i forgot that
it was 40 dollars for whatever reason
and i was totally ready to pay
60 personally but
i just love this game i think that it's
cool that it's going to come out on pla
consoles as well
you know that's going to be a lot of fun
for
for people that um have a switch even
you know like
i think it's it's going to be a fun time
and i don't know
i'm going to play a lot of it that's
that's all i know and so are my friends
so
it's a blast to the past for from the
past fast blast from the past for me
jawbone we'll pick that up
kill wrecking issue hopefully
this is kind of bad being surrounded
like this
but rakanushu seems to be afraid of us
right now so
oh we like almost one shot him
i guess we'll pick up this bow so that
we can give it to our mercenary who will
get one for free i think shortly when i
turn in the quest where's the guy
reviving you guys
look i mean just look at that right okay
hold on let me clear this let me clear
this out for you
and then you'll see what i'm talking
about in terms of um
just the visual difference right like so
look at that look at the fire in that
house
and then look at look at this
i mean
i would say it's a pretty big jump
nico i mean i feel where you're coming
from on that front but i want more
people to experience it i want
people to to realize the greatness that
was like
i
i enjoyed d d3 but i mean d2 is still
number one for me um
and just to have
you know
this a version of like this in the gate
of the game is is i don't know i'm just
super stoked and happy
uh am i six nope i'm five
i will probably get some resist fire in
a second because that synergizes with um
holy fire
and we have one
seven percent extra gold yeah
i think you mix more when you toggle to
the old version really
we should test that theory although you
know a lot of it right now is probably
my attack rating
i didn't put that much dexterity in also
like level so
i know that plays some into it
man j wilson that's a name huh
how many people in uh in the chat hated
the diablo 3 auction house
it's probably going to be like unanimous
even though i personally i liked it but
that's
my personally liking is because i've
made money off of it you know which is
probably the same reason why anybody
would like the auction house compared to
anyone that didn't like the auction
house
i'm going the wrong way aren't i
[Applause]
dark wood where are you or or waypoint
at this point
the game releases september 23rd if i'm
not mistaken
um
i keep thinking 25th but i'm pretty sure
it's 23rd okay cool thanks uh sergio
machado for oh okay we got waypoint
classic soundtrack yep
should have bought more stamina pots huh
darkwood where are you
yeah i was money for the hardcore gamers
for sure
in terms of the auction house
uh ray shack
oh man do we just go back to okay i i
gotta do it i'm just gonna go back to
town so that i can um
get stamina potions because i can't
stand it
how is that only 273 it's got two skills
on it
it's kind of silly
go get um our mercenary
give her
yeah
this ring kind of sucks but i'm not
going to go back to akasha to sell it
like frantically trying to manage these
potions
all right
where did we not
go
oh down
i guess
whimsy shire
did you like that more than cow level i
guess technically in d3 they did add
like a cow
level in the form of um like a rift
right
i'm probably going the wrong way
feels good when you go the wrong way huh
it's not like right above the stones
it's probably
right
no i went there
chat what am i doing wrong
the uh that eagle orb should have been
worth more than like whatever 200
gold
it's kind of nuts but what do i know
cara could dispel the mystery of these
stones she can't without the scroll man
is this coming on console yes mr rigger
it will be
[Applause]
um
playstation xbox and switch
why didn't that work
you don't want to let me drink from the
well even though there's there's water
there
okay
fair enough
it's gonna be like this little segment
down here isn't it
nope
something is amiss
this is very awkward
somehow
you need cave
no it should be
it's usually on a wall though no
oh nope it was
all right i'm going to stop the stream
now now that i failed everyone in chat
that was
that was good huh all right thank you uh
who said caves scabbin thank you i
i just totally thought that cave was
you know like one of those one-off caves
and i did not read underground passage
when if i had
learned to read it would have you know
that probably would have helped um
so
that was fun
go through the cave
yeah yeah sorry y'all
that's usually when i i blame
uh old age and lack of coffee
because you know
all right
uh the only good news is we have the
stoney waypoint
the frame rate for consoles i'm not
exactly sure and i don't want to say the
wrong thing so you probably just want to
look at their like faq
probably
uh also if anyone in chat is curious
uh i can plug in a controller and the
controller function
functionality is actually pretty good we
tried it in the um
the tech test and it was actually pretty
good um it has it kind of has the same
slow down in a way not slow down maybe
that's not the right word to use but the
um inefficiencies of like inventory uh
exists like they do in d3 where you have
to like kind of like pause and stop
playing to like
you know use your inventory and
um
oh did the lobby message duplicate
i didn't even see it
oh
okay i thought we were screwed there it
it definitely uh hitched the game
hitched for a second there that was kind
of scary
all right so
all right so we're going holy fire
and resist fire because holy fire gets
damaged from resist fire
we're gonna switch to holy fire
man i should have put some decks in huh
also the other thing i kind of want to
do but i don't know if we have time is
it wouldn't be bad to farm countess a
couple times to get
uh what's up sid hearth how you doing
it is me tay
um
it would be nice to get like a a steal
which i think is tur l
and then it would be also nice to get
tal eth first death stealth jeez steph
so i don't know if people are bothered
by that then i i won't farm
um countess too much but if not you know
we might
[Music]
oh amulet's always good
we'll use it for now and then sell it
uh
personal account i guess that's good
that you're excited
oh cool so the druid stuff's in i don't
know if the druid stuff was in um the
technical tests like the items
don't need mana
you servers are dead but at least i get
to watch us play
sorry man i
sorry to everyone that's not like eu
that can't play um but i will say
i appreciate um that you're here
watching and hanging out and i really do
hope that they fix it soon for y'all so
y'all can play
do we need dark wood uh no i think if we
get uh or no we gotta get the tree my
bad
uh monty i all i'm gonna say is i'm not
gonna get into the politics of it uh i
enjoy the game and there's a lot of you
know
developers who have spent a lot of time
making this game and
i want to support those folks and i'm
still going to play these games um
that's all i can really all i'm going to
really say about that
i need to find the tree though
let me just show that message really
quick
played two hours until it crashed ah
dang at least you at least you know i
don't know there's not there's no real
good like at least you got to play two
hours that doesn't i don't know you
probably want to keep playing
especially if you didn't have a chance
during the um
technical
test alpha whatever you want to call it
all right we got the scroll which is
good
we're going to kill the rare monster
do we even care about this stuff not
real oh the jawbone cap we might um
how could how can you even see if i did
that um
personal account
all levels are cow levels
i need works leg that's what we're
that's what we're you know gonna go do
yeah the other option like i uh i
mentioned earlier worth trying but i
haven't tried it myself is you could try
switching regions and then see if you
can play on the other region it might
not have your character so maybe you
have to start over but i mean again
outside of maybe having a bit more
latency at least you'll be able to play
at that point oh a torch
yeah i'll take the cap it's got two
socket um
might as well take the resistance
all right so i definitely want to find
the waypoint for
oh no my mercenary
died oops
okay so someone did just in chat say
that you could play on used servers
instead of eu so
maybe maybe just give that a go
give that a go just as a why not and see
um the only downside i see to that is
maybe
maybe needing to um
to have some maybe even have latency you
might not even have latency to be honest
hard to say
oh okay i guess that's not that
i should have read that first but you
know not that we had better gems but
usually when you have gems you want to
try to get a make a perfect you know
if possible
why is that hurting so bad
how can i join a u.s server so in
above the beta there should be a little
globe icon like diagonally to the right
of it and then if you click that it
should show you regions i believe and
then you would just click another region
on the list
now
[Music]
i
want to say you probably need ps plus
for it
but i also haven't tried on on
playstation um yet so
i can't say that definitively
oh
i believe you
do need internet because
in order to even launch it you have to
have the client so
i don't yeah i mean i don't think this
game's over hyped i think you're either
interested as somebody that maybe didn't
play it the first time
or
you did play the crap out of it the
first time like i did and you're just
like cool i get a remastered version
um that i could play on a platform of my
choosing and yeah i'm gonna do that
right so i don't know
all right and then sweet we got the
tower so we're gonna go through the
floors
kill the countess hope for talath maybe
we farm it a couple times since we have
since it's like right next to it and we
can just like kind of open close game
so you might see me do that a little bit
um
just because i think
having stealth is pretty good
and then having like
steel is pretty good because i think
it's got like 50 chance for open wounds
[Music]
for me it doesn't work unable to create
game are you um eu olive to oliver
olivier
so hopefully i said that right sorry if
i didn't
uh and if not if you are eu and that's
not working then maybe try um to switch
a region and then see if that
helps you
these archers are a problem
and block is like good and bad because
it unlocks you so
[Music]
will be cheaper if you already have d2 i
don't think so
it's funny i don't even know if i can
find my physical copy of d2 anymore d2
and llg you know like i think d2 was
three three cds right back cds how many
people in here remember those things um
when you actually needed a cd-rom drive
to install games
um
why are there three of those
and then lod was one i think
too much chatty shut up and play all
right you got it
not along with the 90s
i can't carry anything
question mark now he's fine all right
cool thanks
i mean
i guess i should i should not uh let one
person influence me but if it's the
whole chat then i i definitely or like
you know if you see it multiple times
then yeah it's probably a good chance
that it's bothering people but i
appreciate that
open beta should be the 20th if i'm not
mistaken
um and it should be
at least ps playstation pc playstation
pc uh i don't remember if it's on switch
or not
you'd have to look that up but uh i know
that blizz
or the diablo team has a like faq
uh
and you could probably take a look just
to see what what what's going on there
uh joe bassist
what we mentioned earlier if you're
struggling to get on um
uh we gotta tell ya that's pretty good
uh i think we're gonna run it back
one more time maybe
so i think what people would do is
save exit
we would
go back in
uh sorry so uh i totally lost my chairs
out there um joe so try swapping your
regions and seeing if you can play on us
um
instead and then
that should work for you i think
and then
yeah you'll be able to play at that
point um
or should be able to i didn't repair
greetings
okay
i guess we go to we can go do um
tristram too
hello
did you
why is it
do you realize for the longest time i
never looked at this scroll and it tells
you what the answer is i've always just
spam clicked
hoping for the best
uh yeah i mean there's a lot more blood
there in the old version
i guess it's because
it's like way more pronounced the
splatter
versus the the new i guess
what a tragic end to tristram
yeah oh yeah no problem uh joe and i i
think someone in chat also mentioned
that i think it was sergio if i'm not
mistaken so thanks to sergio for also
kind of recommending the swapping of um
servers uh appreciate you staying and
hanging out in the chat show
and everyone
that's hanging out today uh we really do
appreciate it
we do stream from time to time on game
spot um we might stream more hopefully
in the future if we we can get some
stuff going
and um
yeah
okay so this is a little scary because
one
he curses and curse basically makes me
take like 100 more damage oh this guy
was the one freezing me i thought it was
griswold i was like how is he doing that
to me
so slow
it's not open beta yet it's early access
beta this week and then open beta next
week so if you're looking at trying it
um you wait till next week if you want
to play sooner than that i believe all
you need to do is pre-order and then
that gives you access to the early
access
beta
in that beta right now i i think someone
earlier said it's just act one and two
again i have not confirmed that because
i haven't played it enough yet um
oh do we want words like probably not
right we're not doing any cows today
all right now we save deckard which is
always
you know you want to save deckard
[Music]
and
oh you know what i should just support
to town
so that we can go and do
another countess run which is why we did
it to begin with
and then
um after that we will
go and kill on dariel and then try to
get through act two and then i guess we
can find out for sure oh yeah that's
right
saving
kane gets you a ring that's not very
good but good for money
can't be mad at some money
it's a lot of money there as well um
mute for a second
[Music]
it's locked
[Applause]
uh nervy for the person um saying that
it looks like diablo 3 it might have
some of those hints for you but i
personally think that the
um d2 has definitely more depth uh
you'll see in a second when i get like
when i can try to make a rune word to
show to show um and there's just more
custom
customizability uh in d2 technically in
d3 you're locked to uh six skills right
in um
d2 you have
you can do whatever you want really i
mean there's definitely more optimal
builds but if you wanted to try some
wacky stuff you could do that
um so we're hoping for a tur l right
yeah that's what i said for um
try to get a uh try to make a steal
if we can
look at how cool these
ghosts
there's possibly a way to disable that
in chat um jareth i haven't looked at
the menu options but we could try later
zach are you on eu because i heard eu is
down we're playing on north america so
that might be why
[Music]
yeah and in terms of the gore like for
sure it's i mean we saw the difference
right when i toggled to um
what it looked like
on the old
or like original not old original like
like see there's his there's the blood
marker there but
it's way more splatter
you're on north american xbox and it
doesn't work for you huh
are you talking about multiplayer in
general or are you just talking about
like getting on to play
sorry i might have confused the two
can't carry any
can this run on a potato i don't know my
rig is pretty decent i have a
2080 ti
and an i9 7700k with like 32 gigs of ram
but i mean in theory
right like if it's gonna be able to run
on a switch it probably can run
on on something lower end
oh that's not very good we'll take cold
res six percent on a small charm is
pretty good
um
but the person that's saying it's a
not a fun game for them
you don't have to enjoy it i mean
the beauty of video games is that there
are a lot for people to to play and
enjoy so
you know pick the one that you like
enjoy the ones that you like
if you don't like it and
then maybe you don't have to watch you
know you don't have to you don't have to
ruin it for other people
i burned all the switches in the
universe no
i mean
i love the switch and like
because there's cross save in this game
i
was
possibly contemplating buying
both a uh
uh we only got a rao rune uh i think
we're just going to progress because i
don't want to make y'all watch me farm
um
a tur l so
we'll go do that
and we'll be on our way to andario
hopefully soon
once i sell some stuff
the steam deck yeah it might be i
pre-ordered one um
and from the hands-on i heard oh my
goodness how good would that be i'm
gonna keep that
i
just only because
at some point we will we'll go hammers
and we might not have anything better
than that to be honest um
so there's no harm in keeping that
can you play co-op um
i have not tried but i mean i think the
faq said that there is
multiplayer in this so in theory you
should be able to um
sorry i wish there was a faster way
to do this but that's how it is
oh you know what we should have bought
his stamina push
don't know why it's been doing that
every now and then
chuggy chuggy
yeah the they did some things to improve
the inventory a little bit but it's um
dude that's awesome jareth
yeah i mean i the way i look at d2r is
it it's definitely a nostalgia play for
you know someone like myself who
played a bunch um growing up
and
in the in the prime of my my gaming
you know
uh
and then it's also a play for those that
maybe
um never got to play it and want to
experience it and
i think that's awesome um i really do
think that
uh when d3
reaper of souls came out on on console
that it was
very like i enjoyed it quite a bit i
mean the only thing i didn't enjoy was
the inventory but on console i remember
that you had the ability to actually
send your you know items that
oh whoops i just went back to darkwood
um you had the ability to send like
uniques and legendaries and whatnot that
you had that you weren't using which was
nice that you couldn't really do on pc
that way once you kind of equipped it so
i don't know
oh also technically in d2 there's
uh where am i at i'm at 10 so at 10 i'll
probably uh switch to zeal
oops it was up there that whole time
what was i doing
uh i'll try the the shift clicking to
get it into the inventory later i
probably just
spaced on it i know that shift clicking
works for buying like you know uh buying
out your tomes and stuff like that
it's just been a minute like i didn't
even i don't even know if i put that
much stuff in the stash last last time
the uh during the tech test or the alpha
man everything's got cursed that's not
good
taking that like 100 damage or whatever
let's just run through this
hopefully that was the right choice i
think that um
i'm only one point away from zeel if i'm
not mistaken
even the light cannot pierce this
dude i would love to see more
of this like cinematics just like redone
like all the starcraft ones are so good
i'd love to
see that
be awesome
click on
the game version and not bid oh cool
uh
jojo money 1000 asking is everyone
well door
okay uh is everyone at gamespot working
at home right now uh for the most part
yes um
technically at least for our san
francisco office if uh let me find this
uh waypoint or did i click on the
waypoint i'm spacing out sorry trying to
rechat um most of the most if not all
are are
working from home
and
however in the sf office you can go in
if you if you choose to only if you want
to
um however if you go in because of like
the sf san francisco mandate right now
you have to wear a mask
so
you know as mentioned
i would say probably 90 plus percent are
pretty much not in the office i know
some people that go in maybe like once
or
um
maybe once a week or something or twice
a week just to get a different
environment
um everyone's been at home for so long
that i think some people just enjoy the
change of pace and the
change of scenery
you went there you think they went too
light on the blood
uh i mean
that's a fair argument because look at
this
it's pretty uh
it's crazy how the audio changes huh
like feels like it's like less loud
i don't want that
falchion
because
you know you look at that
and then you look at that and yeah
it's definitely toned down
i mean but then you see that blood pool
there so i guess it's just the enemy
um blood that's kind of like toned down
how long has been working from
home been oh we've been
since last year
april may
so over a year at this point i think
there was some hope that we would go
back in
you know for the people that wanted to
go back in that that there was hope that
maybe by you know august september but
then now with the kind of
acceleration of the delta variant we are
definitely
um
that's not happening
who knows right
uh
we're going
to zeal we're switching to zeal i'm
gonna get some decks
some strength my stats are all over the
place they don't make sense
oh we did not get the malice but it's
fine i mean
you can always get that later
it is a nice quest to get um to give
charissy
the hammer because then she can make a
rare item for you
um of which you can use kind of like
whenever you want uh
you usually want to save it because
it does
better stuff
for you down the road
um then early on unless you're like
maybe speedrunning the game
uh apologies if watching the map thing
is kind of annoying i i'm just so used
to
kind of having it on so that i can
walk around and all that stuff but i
know that that can be kind of annoying
so try to turn that off as much as
possible
just use it to guide ourselves as we get
further
what's your favorite between diablo one
two and three uh for me definitely two
um
but each one kind of holds a different
spot in my heart like one
was really fun because
um
it's like one of the first
arpg
games i played and i was
maybe like one of the one of my earlier
pc games in my time in my uh
childhood and i have to thank that i
thank my cousin tremendously for that
he introduced me to diablo
um let me play it
actually the reason why i like diablo
too was just all the duping so you know
like all the
godly plate of whale and
king staff of apocalypse and
you know all that all that jazz you know
you could walk into a um
you could walk into like one of those
rooms where the people just like kindly
gave you all the dupes
um
yeah i don't know so
and three i i still enjoyed three a lot
i know it got a lot of um
kind of like hate because of the auction
house and then it was kind of really
really really hard in the beginning when
you were playing like towards end game
um which kind of bothered some people
but uh i enjoyed it but
and then i i really think they they had
a big turnaround with like reaper of
souls and i think that
that's kind of when
it took off a little bit more once you
could kind of do adventure mode whenever
you wanted you didn't have to beat this
story every time
it really freed up the game
and
i don't know i there was a time when i
was playing almost every season
oops
um
every like every time there's like an
update and new season with new items
because
it was like oh cool there's a new
legendary that like is specific for the
i don't know amazon or not amazon jesus
um
you know sorceress or or barbarian or
you know oh went the wrong way
the auction house made a lot of sense to
me but again this is coming from
somebody that played a lot and also made
money off of it like you had to have
seen that coming to some degree because
so many people made money off d2 just
selling items and sauces and
i don't know all kinds of stuff right
that was you know being made and duped
and whatever
and so you know at that point you're
probably like well we're not making
anything off of that we might as well
just set something up where we control
it and then also make money off of it so
like i don't know
not the answer everyone wants to hear
but i understand why it existed
and i i benefited off of it personally
so of course i'm i'm gonna like it but i
also can see why um
some folks might not have liked it
also i didn't realize it is friday the
13th so that's kind of funny it's locked
so everyone stay safe
i mean just looking at the like like the
static or the
charge bolt i guess that's like a single
charge bolt it looks like way better
than um
before right
i'm gonna let him hit me ow
yeah
12 mana is not terrible right now i
guess because zeal's eating up the mana
i you know i can't remember all the
names of the
all the different classes at this point
it's been it's been two too too many a
minute um
but
i confuse them all because they're all
like it's demon hunter you know it's but
to me it's like the same thing right
or monk is kind of like an assassin
except doesn't have traps
um
and then you have crusader who's like
you know the character is basically kind
of like an offshoot paladin right in a
way not totally the same not totally
that different either i don't know they
all kind of blend together to me so
you know it's fair that you bring it up
that i can't remember those those exact
classes but hell they're kind of the
same thing
because i'm trying to think like oh man
like i can't even remember the d1
because it's not amazon because amazon
c2
um
is it rogue
someone can correct me in chat i'm
blanking
bait on
console uh it should be on playstation
and xbox uh if you got access or if you
pre-ordered
wow the crystal sword looks nuts
looks so good on the floor compared to
oh but you can easily see it on that one
so who knows
not
no no no in in in d1 in d1
what was what
it was not an amazon right in d1
i'm like pretty sure about that one but
i'm not a hundred
i'm with you on that squirrel master i
i'm 100 with you on that one
and i i would hope other people would
understand that too but you know
apparently i guess not maybe
but it is what it is
um
let's just keep going down that path
all right so in our cloister we're
definitely on our way here
it would be it would have been nice to
have um
a tur l for that cemetary that two
sockets cemetary we could be
rocking a um
what you might call it a uh steel which
is a ruin word uh we did get towelette
though which is nice
oh yikes
why's everything hurting so bad
the damage was real
that is great evil here are you sure my
paladin
warrior rogue mage
there's no monk and d1 is there oh well
i guess if you count the uh yeah okay
it was rogue yeah yeah so it was rogue
and then it became amazon
uh
and then
the equivalent in d3 would be demon
hunter right so
it's locked
uh beta lord
uh
nightbringer only has the
geez this is ridiculous i almost want to
go like lightning res at this point um
it has
the pally or paladin druid
the
amazon
and the sword
sorceress
so in this one it added paladin and
druid is the difference
anyone remember the level i need to be
for stealth
i can't remember it's been so long
anonymous no it's not the
rumored um gta bundle
i don't i don't even know did they even
confirm that i saw i saw the headline
yesterday that that was a thing but i
don't know if they ever
confirmed it
this is a super late response but i
remember someone earlier saying act twos
when you get the cube so
that is correct and who knows if people
are trying to dupe
maybe maybe not
17 bro thank you thank you grim i can't
carry anymore i have a i
have a helm that i could put it in right
now i guess or or we just wear it on um
if i could get a two socket armor maybe
later
at some point
oh man is it down that hall or is it
back near the entrance
that's the question
yeah cross progression as damian says
but no cross save which is why i was
saying that i might
if i did it i would have to buy switch
and i would have to buy um
pc
if i wanted to play on both
but at least the progression sticks you
know all right safety tp
wish us luck
one's in chat if you think i'm gonna
kill and dario two if you think she
kills me
um wish me luck
i'm better off just
using sacrifice against her
hard to say
i don't know if you can try the switch
version here i don't know if that's um
available
uh but i have to double check the faq
one good luck though all right
wow is that really not
registered
oh i think we're okay right oh we're
good we're so good easy easy clap
wow she dropped
not very much my work here is finished
poison attacking sometimes one hit you
uh well it didn't there
uh how are we doing on time so it's been
almost an hour to get through act one
but probably too much
whoa that's a lot of stats but the
damage is low
what
oh just didn't do it the first time
stupid
all right let's try the uh control click
thing into um
stash
yep
control click is the answer thank you
very much forgot who that was so
apologies
keep that for now
where we're going
take me east oh there might be a
cinematic do you all want me to skip it
you want cinematic or not
uh grim the scepter just has two chipped
rubies in it nothing crazy
but the cemetery
the scepter definitely has more damage
than the um
cemetery that we just
i need
i couldn't say
and always
a dark cloud seemed to follow us
just over the horizon
finally the journey
we climbed the last bridge
don't skip skip skip skip don't skip
there's definitely more
it's like 50 50.
[Music]
as you can see it on youtube that is
true psycho commander
perhaps it was the warm desert
they did remaster the cinematics
if you want to see a comparison it's on
youtube.com
the dreams return
the fps might not be as good maybe on
streaming
i remember
seeing you in my dream
his brethren had called a great
they demon to imprison the demon within
a sacred stone
yet
can i still play beta if i pre-order
today i believe so i'll go augusto
now you know what i seek marius
this is my brother
sleep now
we set out with the dawn
the next morning we walked over the hill
toward luke colleen
i had no idea then
of the horrors that were in store for me
there
all right uh so yeah if you want to
watch the greetings
thanks sharon uh if you want to watch uh
higher res
et cetera versions of the cinemax we put
both together on youtube gamespot um
and then also
um
did a comparison so if you want to see
what the old ones look like a part of
the new ones that's also there for y'all
to check out um
should we go sewer
yes go kill
adam
it shouldn't be that laggy normally it
might just be from the one playing it
through the game and then two just like
me streaming it back out
so i wouldn't take that as like
the one to one obviously
[Music]
uh i had the first release of d2 which
was i believe three discs because i
always installed it with three discs
unless i'm taking crazy pills i'd have
to find the old one but it was one of
those like thicker cd um
cases for me uh maybe chad can confirm
or deny that for me
and maybe i'm taking the crazy pills
which
you know
well you know what i should get i should
get a three socket belt oh you know what
i should also did i think it's faster to
go the other side of the um
sewers from the other side because i
think that
that side is um
is usually closer to the uh
what should i call it
to the
waypoint or the stairs
i think
show low res town and then go back i can
do that i'll do that after we kill uh
i call him radiment but it's probably
raven isn't it
butchering names here just know that
killing him gives me an ability or a
skill point
uh xbox has an update but ps5 still does
not sometimes what i would do uh as a
just in case to try um one elite one if
you're on a playstation is like
turn on like you know power down your
playstation then power back up because
sometimes like the playstation itself
needs an update but
yeah unfortunately i'm a pc so i don't
know the current situation on the
console platforms
dino or dino sorry not dino he's um
saying it's he thinks they think it's
also three discs
dead end
what was the keys to send directly to
slash uh i did control and left click
and i might need to put some like
diamonds in my gear because
it's low resistance getting me getting
worked
and i of course do not have any
stamina potions you know when you need
it
i feel like man i don't when i played
this in the tech alpha i don't remember
getting poisoned this much on my
two runs that i did
matthew warsaw says install play disc
and cinematics okay
confirmed it seems at least
um i didn't change anything in the
options sergio i just
i just straight up tried it based off
the recommendation from chat and it
worked right away so
and i have not toggled anything in my
settings um
differently than what's default
and
durial is going to be a scary man
um as a
melee character
the guy basically like stun locks you
and hits you with cold so we will
basically have to bring some of those uh
anti-frozen type potions
there is supposed to be co-op lord um i
haven't tried it though
where is the challenge in this game um
i think
like in terms of like difficulty
it's not terribly hard um unless you're
just like picking the wrong items and
putting like stats into places that you
shouldn't be putting it into
i think it's this game is more about
um
one sec
as i'm getting destroyed right now by
all these
this is kind of bad
i better kill that
yeah okay
oh it is rather man i did have it right
i should hotkey that but i did not
expect to have to
switch to it
attack rating
so there's like the fist of the heavens
right and holy bolt and they look kind
of similar
[Music]
the poison is legit
i don't think you need the scroll but
i'll take it
oh so here's town right so somebody
wanted to see town uh one second
this is town on like remaster right
oh yeah sorry monolith uh gave the
explanation that co-op is no more but
online with other players yes uh sorry i
kind of
mix those two things up because i just
think oh co-op playing with other people
but here's the old luke glenn
and oh you know what's a bigger um here
let me show you in here this is kind of
the more
we did this in the tech test but um this
room is like way different right uh in
remastered
you got some you know carcasses or
hunted
meat there yeah
you got some jars
pots and pans and then here you just
you got a little bit of that i guess you
got some chickens you got a lot of like
like foul like a lot of uh
either chickens or
you know
[Music]
oh 38 attack rating all right we'll take
it
uh let's see what yeah
mara i need a two-socket armor
oh we definitely want a belt uh
i guess we'll take the eight mana belts
but
you don't know that you can trust me
i already stopped there at garlic yeah
right i mean who knows
playing grim dawn until d2 releases did
that i only played a little bit of that
in the beginning when it first released
um swallowing the c like
has it gotten a lot better the other
game i really kind of enjoyed that i
haven't played since it released two was
uh wolsen lords of mayhem
that was a pretty fun game too
show skill trees uh i'm currently on the
holy fire path i have some resist fire
because it synergizes i think we'll
eventually
around 18ish if we make it that far
we'll switch to um
hammers
is the plan at least um
but i mean i think i'm gonna have to
book it if we want to do that um to kill
on dario because i probably have
i don't know it's 12 30 now started
around 11 30. probably half to about 1
30. so we have about an hour it's
possible
possible to at least get to um
durial and see if we can kill him
um
don't know if we'll have enough time to
respect because it might just not be
worth the time
but we'll get there i mean
dude
the the
details on like even this
looks a lot better man
all right
well not so much those but the the
like the slingers over there and
oh right i did not
oh this
oh
it's frost nova holy smokes
is this a preview of
what's his name muriel
i have the preserved head
oh somehow i killed him earlier too okay
that's weird
so tired of missing
oh do we get lucky
i believe cube is in dry holes right
[Music]
let's put money in the storage yeah i
could i'm it's fine
i'll get it back i'm
well well i probably just jinxed it
right by saying that
wait why doesn't that go into the belt
oh i have to have one in there okay
all right halls of the dead get our cube
then we got to get the the neck from the
viper
valley
and then we gotta get the staff from the
maggot lair
then after all that we're gonna have to
go and
sanctuary
the sanctuary arcane sanctuary
and then we'll get all the way to uh
durial
still ways to go
nostalgia is a powerful drug cadmus i
mean think about all the movies that are
coming out too right like
it's it's not just uh games that are
using nostalgia
this has to be better right
nostalgia hell of a drug
also the funny thing too cat is like i
was willing in my head for some reason i
thought this game was gonna be sixty
dollars and i already like in my head
committed to the fact that i was like
i'm probably gonna pay 60
and then it was 40 and it was more of a
pleasant surprise of like oh
actually
i'm okay with it i guess i don't know
but that's me right that's not everyone
um
i
don't know bastiano i don't know i
didn't see it just now for to turn on um
hardcore but
i can try to check for you later before
we end the stream if you want to remind
me to look at it
okay what did i miss
i literally
oh no there's probably one more path in
the beginning right
no
strange
i'm pretty sure this corner is a dead
end though so i don't know why i'm
coming down here
okay maybe this is another like senior
moment where i just can't see it
um
that is strange
all right gonna lean on chat's expertise
we should be in halls of the dead right
to get cubed
and technically there should be a way
down right
am i crazy for thinking that
i like zeal or vengeance for paladin yes
both are very good
um
oh is it over there oh my gosh
how okay
okay
it blended in how could i see that it
was so tiny
wrong tomb we're not at that point yet
but yes that could easily happen too
later
um if you don't look at the book and
figure out what symbol you're supposed
to actually click
so there's the pros and cons of having a
shield
as you saw i got like semi stun locked
because of block
this is quite annoying
yeah i just
i just couldn't see the little room and
i was using the map more than actually
like walking up to the uh certain
section so that makes a lot more sense
this is the wrong way clearly
but thank you uh t why
what are the odds
oh that's kind of scary
all right
the only problem is i don't think oh
this kind of sucks um
[Music]
i guess we hey it wasn't that far from
town right
i think we'll be okay
well i just got in said evie what a
great time to be alive yeah enjoy
thanks for stopping by
oops this one was better
what how whatever
no three socket i need two socket armor
all right
[Music]
oh we need to buy pots
good day
i think we ditched this uh 12 mana charm
oh i should
[Music]
yeah you can't switch between controller
mouse and keyboard
i mentioned that earlier if anyone wants
to see what controller gameplay looks
like i can do that i just have to plug
it in it's pretty good
uh
it plays a lot like
what you would expect uh on like d3 and
stuff like that
controller wise
john boswell says let's get it baby all
right you got it i will i will try to
get it
15.
technically two away from a stealth but
we don't have an armor for it i don't
think this has sockets
love the rubber banding there
i need a key
do you guys ever use gamble or just
relied on farming for good gear uh i
gambled here and there if we if i had a
lot of money but i've
honestly barely ever got lucky from
gambling uh a lot of what i did was just
farming
um either like meph runs or uh
pendle
i didn't need that considering there's a
well there
chat remind me um
for stealth can i
put that in helm too i can't remember
definitely no armor i know it works on
armor rather
or was that the other ruined word
i was trying to shop for one grim didn't
find one
but i mean technically we have a level
and a half before it even matters
so
lightning rush
i can't yeah i can't remember i know um
i might be thinking of something else
for the helm that you could do that
works in multiple um
i know there what was it like nefort or
something like that
or
something something with an ort in helm
gave you like plus one to skill and then
also worked on shield
uh pj tv says i don't like the console
button settings like holding square for
selling
i'm putting item in the stash can you
can you remap though pj
or soul okay that that's what it was
yeah definitely well tallahat is still
good for a movement speed though 25
movement speed right uh mistaken
oh you're on ps5
huh i'm surprised they don't let you
i can't remember if they even let you in
uh d3 though to be honest
[Music]
yeah i mean the one thing that i've
always not liked so much on console is
like inventory management stuff uh
because you basically have to
um oh you know what um
how do we best do this
it would be better oh
i think i'm not that far from dry hill's
waypoint so we'll just we'll just do
this we'll just do this it'll be fine
yeah it kills light radius right yeah oh
chain
boots i'll take that
and that
uh hey there's faster hit recovery so
that's always good and some res we'll
take it
seven of life not good enough
i really needed some
freaking lightning res
and poison res i guess
teleport is king yeah well
i'd love to teleport i'd love to have um
the what you're gonna call it uh
hammerton's best friend armor
rune word see that's that's the like one
thing i was i was mentioning earlier
about just how there's more
customizability in
diablo 2 because you can technically get
an armor on a paladin that lets you like
teleport
like a
like a sorceress
or wizard however you want to
call it and then
you know you could go crazy auras um by
giving your mercenary is it in
infinity
forget which uh two-hand like pole arm
spear thing that you could
basically give to your act ii mercenary
which by the way actual mercenary number
one
i know there's some builds that use
um
other mercenaries but
act two's always been my favorite you
just get like a holy freeze one or
something
and it just helps out quite a bit
sure
what's the most op skill in your opinion
is it like hammers like one of the most
op because of the fact that it's like
magic damage and it's like
doesn't really get resisted by most
stuff yeah it's an enigma thank you
james ferguson um i forgot the the ruin
word i just remember what it could do
oh wait did anyone else um
i think act one work is okay i'll i'll
aerith sorry geez
um
but actually is usually the the number
one the number one bae
how are we doing on okay i got half an
hour ish to try to um
we'll see
oh wait no i have more than half an hour
to do it okay
whoa my guy was going crazy there
i don't know if anyone saw it but
he looked
like he was going to zeal town you know
he said it right okay cool
my chat and my bad eyes poor vision
uh jen's hoffman i
don't have an ultra ride so i can't
confirm or deny that but i'm sure it
would be in the
faq
i don't think it's useless info i i view
it as memories right um
memories that you won't forget
age is what's catching up to me please
close the map i'll try
i'm just so used to it because it just
helps me get to where i need to because
otherwise we're kind of guessing a
little bit but i will try my best to
open this closed door
okay that's fine there's no there's
there's nothing over there right so it's
fine
uh
knucklehead
cool to have you here
time to go back to d3 no no i
i have not gone back and with d2r coming
out i probably will never go back to d3
it'll be the d2r and then d uh d4
whenever
that happens like what 20 to 22 maybe
who even knows
what's your build right now i'm just uh
spamming holy fire but
in theory i would go um oh jeez
look how fast it loads though huh um i
would probably go hammers at at 18
technically
it'd be the the better build
but um
the crazy thing too is like i have a 10
faster cast rate amulet
wait
and with like towel after probably
you know what that axe might actually
have more damage
so probably check it in a
and second everywhere
is it better
i don't think
oh it's got 107 attack rating i guess
we'll see we can we can feel it out
i'm more excited for this than d4 i hey
i can understand that 100
i mean we haven't seen enough of deep
ward to make you feel like
more certain about that game and you
know what you're getting here
no
i'm with you uh lauro
this was a game that me and my friend
always joked that you know if they they
brought it back we'd like
lose our lives again because like we
just spent so much time playing this
game
um and here it is
of course it's like you know five years
later and we both have kids now but hey
um
this is the kind of game
that
i want my kid to play when he grows up
and
i might even do the thing where like i
haven't played but then i haven't played
like this
no that'd be kind of cool huh
some games like i don't know as much as
i love d2 i feel like it like didn't age
as well
down the road um and i'm really happy to
that's personal opinion and i'm really
just happy to have
this version be a thing
can't wait to fight the agents again
wow i freaking one shot him oh i guess i
didn't really one shot him because holy
fire was probably the thing doing work
but
that thing died huh
what was it like i think like the staff
is actually legit on a druid if you
finish it and you combine it with the
necklace the amulet
thus
good evening
uh let's check for that two socket armor
no
all right
yeah we need some potions huh first
piece of the staff
[Music]
are there maces for paladins yeah i mean
the scepter that i was using is
basically uh specifically for the
paladin
as we rush our way back to
the next area so that we can go
uh how is it running running well for me
i have a
what somewhat average above average rig
probably above average um
but it's running good for me there's
been a couple stutters or hitches where
i
actually thought maybe i'd dc from the
game but
um
so far so good the only time we got to
main menu was when i forcibly went to
main menu myself
so
oh easy to respect uh
correct me if i'm wrong
chat um do you get three now is it one
per uh difficulty or is it just one uh
you can respect through
akasha but i think it's like one
per difficulty so you still kind of
gotta be
mindful of it but i could totally be
wrong because i haven't played in a long
time because that was something that
came later
back in the day when i played a lot uh
you basically if you screwed anything up
stats wise or whatever you basically
would be messaging your friend and
saying like hey
um can you give me a quick
level
quick level up so that i can go do bail
runs and then do that again in nightmare
and then do that again in hell
there's no way it was in the top left
right where the the maggot den was
oh there it is
and we level which is good
oh we're 17.
sure
it'd be nice to have that towel left
right now
and some people are persistent huh
i'm proud of the rest of chat i just
want to say that
all right so it gets darker when you
trigger the lost city area
if uh some of y'all didn't know
the um
it's a viper temple that's probably not
the right name but the
that monster is scary as a melee
character because that person can kind
of like lock you up too
[Music]
i
i think it can um jan but
you said i7 um
and then like what kind of graphics card
i guess
i'm sure everything can be it can be run
it's just a matter of like
what um
quality it'll end up being
it might not stop right
we've got an l ruin which is nice so now
all we need is a tur rune and then we
can make our steel which will also be
nice
i can't carry any
i mean i think he can still run it
though because i feel like
again and i'm not
crapping on the switch because i i
actually enjoy it and i think that this
game is going to be fun on the switch i
think that if it can run on the switch
it should be able to run on that
you know the same rig that or laptop
that you played d3 on like that's my
guess
obviously harder to tell without knowing
for sure
but
it's all like i said it's all kind of
relative to like what you want the game
to look like at that point
i'm guessing i'm gonna stamina potions
of course
love it
oh that's fine
on the switch joke
i mean i wish they kind of improved the
performance but maybe it doesn't matter
right like that's just not the
that's not what that's that platform's
going for okay well we got the waypoint
since i'm here i always just make sure
that there's nothing sneaky going on
because i hate it when i have to go back
and it's like oh you just totally missed
that one spot
uh
okay so we came down from there
oh wait
what
the heck
is it back up there and i just found the
waypoint probably huh
pcs are greater than consoles yes
unless you have an old pc and have a new
console i guess
where are you claw viper temple
oh this is not good he's freezing me
ah
uh i don't think you can take your beta
character into the game but i believe
um they did say that you could like load
saves right they probably won't work on
ladder but like i think you can
have your saves
um
be used in the uh
like non-ladder stuff i'm not mistaken
and somebody's probably gonna like
back check that again on me but
i think that's accurate
tp is your friend sometimes
wow
uh
i haven't heard that one yet uh patrick
in terms of the crashes so sorry to hear
that
what's the difference between the old
version and this version i think is what
you're asking pedro
um
higher fidelity of
uh
in terms of just
look and feel and then there's also um
some quality of life stuff they're
adding i think it auto picks up gold now
which it didn't used to uh that was kind
of annoying because you'd always have to
like manually pick up gold so i'm
thankful for that that's kind of like a
d3 feature
trying to think of other stuff there's a
cross
save cross regression there's better
stash stuff um so that you
it's more efficient than it used to be
where i think he used to have to mule a
lot you know to get stuff into the stash
so there's a shared stash
um
see this whole getting charged by these
snakes is what happens from the boss guy
at the
lower level
what is in the way
i'm not crazy right okay it was lag it
was lag
should have always been auto pickup yeah
a different time you know i could see
why you would not though because it's
it's i don't know you got it it's like
uh that whole time sink thing right
where
you know you have to pick up gold so
then all of a sudden it's like it takes
you like way longer
i don't know there's a lot of stuff
even back in the world of warcraft days
where
you know you could go probably go make a
sandwich in the time that you got from
one
city like one kind of far out city to
another right so
i think diablo is 21 diablo 2 is like 21
i think
i think it came out in 2000 if i'm not
mistaken
i should pick up that staff but
make sure it's not over here before i go
all the way
right might be at the door here
maybe
yeah
all right so tp
case
don't know how he just got destroyed but
we'll take it
all right we got the necklace
all right
excellent hi
good day good day deckard
good day
these are some really bad rings huh
good day
oh you know what we need to check we
need armor huh
man she is being stingy
about to go buy some like leather armor
at this point
charcy hook me up
thanks dan i really appreciate those
kind words and i'll i'll try to relay
that to the team um
it means a lot means a lot uh for
everyone hanging out here
thank you
when i fled the monastery
uh
only because we're just wait
no studded armor right
all right only because we we are on a
time
here we got a
towel
so there's a ruined word if you've never
seen a ruined word before
um
this one's pretty good so we're gonna
put that
bad boy on look at how much faster we
run now
feels good
gotta go fast like sonic
all right so if i'm not mistaken
oh
no i will not i will what
wait
talk to dragonin right
all right go to arcane sanctuary i think
we're gonna make it
i really would like an l ruin
so that i could um
make steel but you know hey if that
doesn't come to fruition then
not the end of the world
like look at
how much detail there is now
how do i have frost resist and i'm still
getting
blown up
this makes sense
i like don't feel like i ever really
like cleared this area i think i always
just like rushed through it and got to
like hurricane sanctuary
also this damage is kind of real
oh i'll take that
rosters is not cross community fair
still annoying
you would think it would be more
beneficial
but this is
that is
accurate stephen thank you
i think it's stephen if it's not stephen
and it's stefan sorry but i think it's
stephen
think
i will uh before we end the stream later
i'll try to hop into like
someone else's game if that's the thing
i don't even know if it is right now
so
in theory we could
try to respect
probably won't though
all right i'd like to open this door
those guys are annoying
run i'm trying to run
i'll try that next time for the armor
but we got lucky
uh so not the way huh
there it is
weird that that guy's not trying to hit
me but all right
all right what are the chances
chat
which way which way
one in four chance
one and four
where should we go
oh we could add a point of vengeance
left bottom so this one
oh no not this level so this way
bronson is this your best guess this way
north east
never eat shredded wheat so northeast
but
he's down top oh no
is this lyric no i'm not lyric
top left
about east down
north
okay the mo i've seen the most is east
right so so we're either going down one
of these paths right so
we just need to pick one
opposite of the circle all right all
right russ
this is on you if we don't make it there
okay
definitely not where i was on the screen
huh everyone
and then russ is probably just going to
tell me later but that's not what i
meant i meant the other way
ah i mean so far so good maybe
maybe
can you make classic mode and then swap
yeah sure
this is what it looks like
um kind of like og version
also we are struggling right now to kill
anything
oh there's a charm i think i gotta go
back for that in case it's a small charm
because small charms are just too good
oh it's a grand charm of course
oh there's an amulet though
it's kind of bad
sure
and i need pots potions though
oh watch this be two sockets okay good
jeez
uh all right only because i'm out of
potions i have no choice
i would prefer not to rip on the stream
and if i'm gonna rip it it's gonna be
the durian over some stupid reason
probably
hello
i don't even know why i bought the dog
potion we're not even there yet
greetings
oh
i mean so far so good maybe though i
mean we kind of got a far we kind of got
pretty far all things
i can't tell
[Music]
i mean
oh there's a lot of stuff over there
so this bothers anyone i can switch back
oh wait i just wanted a circle huh i
better go back the other way hold on
hold on wait a minute
we gotta make sure that
we gotta check on what uh
russ
picked
okay
oh russ
batting a hundred
wow weezowie good job russ hey everyone
give russ a shout out in the chat
he chose wisely
seekers of the two
seekers
okay so pro tip right uh is it
wait
wait doesn't the book tell you which one
it is because of the tomb of tal rasha
will find it through them
i always thought the book told you what
it was uh
man
i'm spacing right now because of the
tomb of tower russia we'll find him
because i think it's supposed to tell
you in the yeah there you go see it
tells you which one it is
bow before me
all right so let's find triangle
triangle according to this is down this
way
so if you if you have if you if you ever
were confused about which one to go to
and you didn't want to go to the wrong
two then um make sure to click the quest
and i'm i don't know why it's it's just
a big circle i don't know why i said it
was down this way
well clearly it's
that's not how the tombs are designed
hold on let's go find it
all right that is circle
okay and then we gotta go all the okay
basically it's like this huge kind of um
l shape
i also just
showed it like thinking you guys could
see me on camera but you can't that's an
undersided i don't know
half circle
square
don't need that
like a star
oh i i can't i can't
okay look at how much better that looks
the map is even clearer
triangle all right we got a winner
there's a triangle
oh no
stop stealing my mana
oh
um
this damage is uh not so nice
kind of nervous about uh
mr durial
okay more backwards cool
going to die
i think this is the wrong way
oh maybe up here
nope we just went in a circle
i'm gonna be mad if it's on that far
right oh
not cool
very trapped
there's a lot of minions over here huh
um
oh you know what i should have got
oh holy shield's until 24.
oh dead
you run this build end game or respect
i'd respect later uh easiest is probably
hammers right
just in general
okay we're in trouble
sorry we need pots um
hello
greetings
good evening
yeah you can you can plug in if you're
on pc you can plug in a controller um
and it works pretty just pretty much
plug and play
i should have pro think that that's that
uh smoke spear
but
okay door just
just vanished and opened for me which is
nice
okay
unfortunate
hopefully it's down that other path
you guys are so annoying
you could do walking hammered in yeah
good
i don't think this is the way
am i crazy i mean it definitely said
triangle
and i've definitely
feel like we're in the triangle one
but i've also feel like i've gone
everywhere
oh except down there and like i said
earlier i'm gonna be super mad right
that it's gonna be in that one spot
we're already at
uh
yeah i mean if you're trying to farm
from the beginning and you're starting
fresh sork or amazon to some degree even
could be uh the way to go just because
you you do get uh you can do uh
lightning fury or whatever which is like
pretty easy to manage i think
alright we found it
all right we buy some
i don't even know how much it matters
but we'll get some anyways
greetings
and
blessings to you
how do i juggle this
yes
feels like this is kind of overkill
though huh
all right good luck us
well actually i should make the tp
inside huh
although i guess maybe it doesn't matter
another day
all right
all right let's go kill mr durial
the question is one's in chat if you
think i'm gonna die two if you think i'm
gonna kill
or it
i'll probably open a tp in there this is
gonna be
real scary
he surprisingly hasn't froze me yet but
not like this stereo no
the chat wants to see me live
no
dang it
all right the chat was right
rip
rip
it's because i didn't have the the
rejuve in my belt
i didn't even need this thawing potion
stupid
all right
yes i'm looking for bail
you're dead this time i swear it
uh
he should have died the first time chad
that's my bad
you hate to see it also he dropped the
worst of loot my gold back
all right cool we'll take that belt sure
uh
technically tyrio should be here and
it's a pretty good
visual difference too if you want to see
that
because there's mr tyrial right i thank
you for my thinking
but i did expect you were over here and
then look at this
i came here to prevent diabolo from
freeing his brother baal
but they have failed
now terror and destruction roam free
through outdoor world
even now they head towards the eastern
capitol of kurosta to the very heart of
the zapalu
though it is unclear as to what their
aims are it is certain that they must be
stopped at all costs
i am broken and the energies that tie me
to this world are diminishing rapidly
you must take up this quest and prevent
the three brothers from reuniting you
must cross the sea and search for diablo
and bale in kurust
now hurry
time is running out for all of us like
look at his like little wings at the top
or like not the wings but you know what
i mean like his shield just look at his
wings
i don't know it's so cool
the lava
the lava doesn't even move
i guess his like the his actual wings
are like bigger here
but his armor is basically chromed out
show us act three i don't think there is
but we can we can attempt to do it we
can see if mr jarrod will
or is it uh wherever
um
oh man forget his name
i should just be control clicking i
don't know why i'm doing that
man she still didn't have one huh
uh all right let's i don't think i don't
think it's gonna work though
good
talk to michief that's his name
do you exist in the beta
are you here
mischief
oh
greetings jiren tells me
my ship is your ship
uh he doesn't exist i mean i'm sorry he
does exist but he doesn't let me um
okay let's look at lobby we're in the
lobby
okay
okay uh-huh we could use a join a game
yeah ladder ladder character we don't
have any ladder yet join a game we can
jo oh
uh d2r
a baby act one new pally act two go go
b smith
what do you guys want to see you want me
to join a bigger one tryst run 03 baby
or tombs o2
that's that's a long one
they're farming they're farming let's do
it tombs o2
look at all these folks
trying to like level up can i get a tp
oh look at all these teepees
oh conviction
he's a hammer boy
let's see let's see what do you got man
what do you got can i inspect
uh uh dude here you go
take my take my flawed diamond man
yeah i traded with them
uh it's too bad you can't see their uh
so he's running hammers right he's going
he's going with a uh probably fcr
little wand there
which is what we would probably want um
did he clear this out up here's everyone
else so here's here's the multiplayer
there's some druid someone's got level
two
two swords all right all right
that one's cleared
well i'm seven isn't it eight i think
it's eight right
because i'm number seven right now
oh it's just like the old days where you
gotta fight for luke
it's like whoever oh
do y'all remember pick it did you guys
have a picket before
it's whoever can get it first
i don't
know if i can go hostile
oh no
this one remind me how to go hostile
man it's really too bad you can't see
their gear that would be sick
i want to know i want to know what he's
running he's running vengeance aura
with um
you know hammers although i didn't see
any hammers go you know
[Music]
allow me to advise you
surprise he's not shape-shifting as a
druid but maybe he doesn't need to
he's like barely throwing any hammers
there you go oh the hammers look good
you see those hammers the hammer is
looking good
you're not doing any damage though
or it's just like really slow to show it
because like look those are the old
hammers right
dude i can't wait
oh man i gotta i gotta tell my friends
to log on
later tonight so i can uh so we can do
some multiplayer do some tomb runs
see how the hammer boy is such a classic
name yeah
hell i don't even know if i've been
doing damage i feel like i'm not
oh there's a superior flail no
i don't want that
are we done with this one
are we going to another one which one
have you like i don't even know which
ones they haven't cleared yet
um not everyone can do uh oh that's not
fair she gets to freaking teleport
not everyone can do it yet because it's
not open beta
elect oh yeah he's just running straight
charge bolt
yeah i don't i don't feel like i'm a
contributor
i'll find out right here
hard to say hard to say nope it's
definitely that charge bolt sword
that's not fair man that's just not fair
that's weird
come on hammer boy you can do it
oh
you're too slow i i looted faster
west or east us west
oh man that's that's back in the day
right there
gotta be fast gotta be fast
oh
oh small charm
no he was faster than me
oh man these sorry sorry if i'm getting
excited for stupid stuff it just brings
me back
really was who could pick stuff up
faster because you hear a small you hear
a charm and you're just spam clicking
like jewel
see they're too fast
too fast i'm too slow
oh he has charge too that's nice for
movement for movement
i don't know hammer didn't have problems
killing this fire tower so am my though
oh we're done with this one next next
two next two
oops
but the wrong way got too excited all
right i'm gonna do like one more two
maybe and then we'll probably call it
i just wanted to show the functionality
and it seems like it's working fine
right
oh man did he drink from the well twice
come on now you gotta share
everyone's thirsty
oh bone one
oh if they snooze that one's gonna be
worth some money
oh it hurts
it hurts so bad
the dune beetles don't mess around with
six people in the game
see like it's not even hurting him like
what
all right i gotta see this hammer damage
because it's supposed to be so good
okay
oh yeah no actually
i don't maybe it just wasn't registering
earlier
oh i have no pots this is not good
i believe though
man frost armor so good
i don't know sork is just too good in
the beginning i feel like once you kind
of get rolling
oh i don't want to be in there
i heard a gem
isn't there like a really easy like
shield to make too that has fcr i swear
it's like
is that the tal ralph
port one
sword is good forever that's true
i can't dispute that at all
i mean especially when you don't have
gear like it's too good
like frost orb
whoa the lightning sound got really loud
huh oh am i gonna die here
i'm
i'm definitely getting carried right now
oh no
save me
wow that guy picks up rejuve so fast
all right all right
not going to die here
spirit taural or am really
that's four though isn't it
i thought it was just the three like
main ones tile row and orb probably
all right let's go back down let's go
back down
if i cleared it
i mean i do decent damage unless the
fireball caught up there
yeah i don't know it's cool this is it's
cool to be able to join other people's
games um
i don't know i mean i could get i could
get blessed hammer right now it's just
gonna be really bad
uh where is it
time to be a walking hammer did
my lord
the rubber band
oh wait did someone go pvp oh oh
someone's hostile
i think
or they're dead
oh no they're just dead bodies okay
whoops
how did they die
is that even doing damage like not
really huh
does that feel off at all
i don't know
that that doesn't feel that great
but it might be because i don't he had
conviction in order near me too
so i don't know
yeah well
um
all right
let's see
does that really boot me all the way out
okay cool okay so here's lobby
there's world chat
yeah
anyways um
really appreciate everyone hanging out
today
checking out some diablo to resurrected
paladin gameplay we'll come back next
week in the during the open beta
and i'll play druid even though again
not my favorite character at all
uh but it's hey but it's it's still fun
to to try it out
um and yeah i i hope that all those that
were having problems playing earlier get
a chance to play um during the early
access beta
um but
you know if you want to check out the
cinematics we have those up on
youtube.com slash gamesbot if you want
to
see a comparison of the old cinematics
of the new ones we also have that on
youtube.comgamespot
really appreciate all the support and
all those that tune in
um it is friday totally forgot about
that so i really hope that everyone has
a great week
um looking forward to it really the
multiplayer just joining
kind of those you know tomb run 001 to
like whatever it is or bail runs
eventually when we get there is fun
stuff and i hope
um
y'all get to get to experience it and if
not
definitely next week when it's open
but until next time
i'm going to meet myself and we'll see
y'all later i really do appreciate
everyone hanging out today it was really
really fun time
you